So, we have arrays and we have arraylists, and it's
a bit of a nuisance that we have both. Because it
means that we have to make a decision between them
whenever we want to collect elements. Generally, arraylists are more convenient
because they can grow and shrink. But there are a
few reasons why you might want to prefer arrays. First off, the
syntax for the brackets, is more compact. For example here,
we assign values one to values two and that's a bit
easier to read than the equivalent with arraylists, which
you see over here. Also, if you know exactly what
values you want in a collection, then arrays give you
an easier syntax. Here I have a string of workdays,
and I know exactly that I want these five
strings. No more, no less. I know what they are.
Then I can use this handy syntax, to construct an
array and initialize it right away. With an array list,
I would have to call the add method five times,
once for each of these strings. Another disadvantage of array lists
is that they don't work well with numbers. We have
never done that so far, but let's say we wanted to
collect Numbers in an array list, I'd have to do
something like this, and when you look carefully, you'll notice that
the double here, has an uppercase D. Normally, when we
want to have a floating point number, we write double with
a lowercase d, and you may recall that the
number types are not classes in Java. But inside, the
angle brackets here, I must put in a class.
An array list can only collect objects of a class.
So for every number time, There is a companion
class, called the wrapper class. And an object, of a
wrapper, just has some number inside. If you have
lots of numbers, say for the sake of the argument
you have, 1,000,000 values, it takes a lot more
space to store 1,000,000 wrappers each of which contains
a number, than it would be to use an
array That's contains the numbers directly. Most of the
time, we're not that concerned about efficiency, but when
you are, and need to collect a lot of
numbers, definitely use an array. In conclusion, use an
array list as a rule of thumb, unless you want
the nice syntax that an array gives you. You having the brackets, having the
initializers. Or you collect lots of numbers.
In that case, array lists are quite inefficient.